encuentra y verifica tu respuesta aunque
tenemos aquí que a las 5 es igual a 54 y
eso qué es lo que quiere decir quiere
decir que aquí tenemos un número o una
variable que a la hora de que le sumamos
5 nos queda 54 y tal vez puedes hacer
esto muy rápidamente en tu cabeza pero
lo que vamos a hacer en este vídeo es
hacerlo de una forma sistemática porque
eso nos va a servir cuando nos
encontremos con problemas un poco más
complicados y si lo que queremos es
encontrar
y tenemos una ecuación que tiene a la
variable bueno a la letra a entonces lo
que queremos es hacer que ésta a se
quede solita completamente solita del
lado izquierdo del igual esa es la forma
más fácil de encontrar
y para hacer eso pues lo único que
tenemos que hacer es deshacernos de este
más 5 y hay una forma muy fácil de
deshacernos de ese más 5 y eso es
simplemente restándole 5 aunque hay por
qué pues porque cinco menos cinco es
cero y entonces tenemos aquí a más cero
que simplemente a cierto bueno pero
queremos que se preserven esta igualdad
entonces todo lo que le hagamos del lado
izquierdo del igual y se lo tenemos que
hacer al lado derecho del igual en que
hay entonces aquí tenemos 54 y también
le tenemos que restar 5 por acá y
entonces lo que nos queda es a más 55 es
igual a más 0 y aquí lo que tenemos el
50 y 45 que eso es 49 y listo entonces
ya terminamos a es igual a 49 ok esta es
la respuesta ya encontramos aaa y ahora
lo único que nos falta es verificar la
respuesta ok entonces para verificar
nuestra respuesta lo que tenemos que
hacer
es verificar que en efecto si es igual a
49 entonces a 5 es igual a 54 aunque
tenemos que ver que 49 porque es igual a
49 más 5 es igual a 54
49 5 es 54
y 54 pues sí es 154 entonces si se da
esta igualdad ok ya terminamos